[Musica]
ciao a tutti vi sono aspartame celebrano
da cui prende il nome
come disco
[Musica]
come dentro e bronchi l'aria fresca ci
aspettavamo nel una maledetta ci
scontriamo ancora ci scordiamo mollo
colpo di testa
alle doria
aspetti
non ci scrivo denti
ma va
pensate a parte
sa dare mi abbraccia per sentirmi meglio
sa stare conteneva solo se non sei
non cercavo o niente è messo in mezzo
[Musica]
passavano
non provare a vincere è la ragione
ma si asporta a me e per me
bastavano
gelati ma confonderci
siamo piccoli
passi
[Musica]
noi seduti sopra in marcia gatti
insomma e mostri come
però ci dimentichiamo come scar a
[Musica]
poca
distanza
ansa
insomma un'altra
schiano
[Musica]
passavamo
non provare a vincere la ragione
male già spetta a me e per me
bastavano
gelati ma a confonderci
cagliari
20 mila anni passati noi 16 marcia gradi
[Musica]
9 set
ma
mi passati
seduti su marzo
[Musica]
non so dare è
quello che non so
meola
oggetti
passavano
la notte a stringersi
[Musica]
[Applauso]
mi sono capitati bello un po più peso
nidal disco
è successo mi spiace
però quando vi pare un sacco di
positiva il
prossimo meno siamo se tre amici
[Musica]
brigate rosse sul comodino
segno due barre solo attacco
[Musica]
paci sopra la cui destino
c'è un bambino
doveva dirmelo ma non charlie
sull effetto
cacchio d'alema
e lampioni lontani
quando si ferma
ancora ciao
[Musica]
siena scappa dati sbagliati
sono un po
sì
se teheran
[Musica]
cena sugli alberi graffiti stazione i
graffi del gatto tutti abbracci del
termosifone
cambiamo i colori le luci del televisore
scappa spero non ha le fosse di venere e
sento lo sport
e se incompleto lo cannes per l'infinito
stare insieme a mazzi sfiorare la
scottarsi fare vedi sorrisi di amanti
baciami ancora
[Musica]
vecchia dalle
alluvioni
lontani
quando si è fermi
[Musica]
baciami ancora se tieni
diciamo grazie
scarpa di sbagliato
di quella
quando si è fermi
baciami ancora se ti ami
[Musica]
ma sono povera ma se trami
[Applauso]
[Musica]
sistemando tutto la studio lino
posto ci siamo
io non volevo parlare
non mi hanno costretto perché non è una
violenza unito a un certo punto hanno
convinto ha detto magari qualcosa di non
c'è una storia incredibile non c'è una
storia tragica non
sarebbe bello insomma però non è stato
bello pure non averla la tragica insomma
però non mi so spiegare 4 non ho
lavorato tutta la vita ho sempre fatto
la musica perché è quello che
mi sentivo
non sono mai stato troppo
attento alle definizioni e questa quello
non usiamo questo non sono le relazioni
rapporti per un certo punto mi sono
chiesto mattina e la musica
la risposta ce l'ha avuta in parte con
un musicista italiano si chiama tony
carnevale e dice la musica a quell'arte
che utilizza i suoni come mezzo di
trasmissione
la quale passa da una fantasia che la
compone una fantasia che le labbra e la
elabora quindi l'ascoltatore non essendo
tangibile la musica senza l'ascoltatore
non esiste e senza un altissimo che nel
tempo ha bisogno di avere quello che c'è
stato prima e quello che c'è stato dopo
ettore petrolini un attore e autore
italiano cantava tanto che canta perché
mi sento un frizzi con er core ora era
veramente cardiopatico dovete vedere
però già iniziato un po cioè è ovvio la
canzone canzone d'amore ha però già
iniziamo entrare un po no
nei termini di autore e compositore
ascoltatore
la musica si muove di pari passo con il
progresso tecnologico con
la situazione politica con la situazione
sociale insomma tantissime cose
nell'esempio il microfono
ragazzi vi rendete conto grazie al
microfono ci siamo liberati dei cantanti
lirici
una cosa da poco ragazzo
però è il canto lirico nasce apposta per
essere sentito nei grandi teatri c'era
bisogno di tanta potenza
adesso mi sentite anche se pare lusi e
quindi
ci siamo liberati pure della batteria a
volte essere molto peggiore
dell'universo ragazzi magistrali tempo
allora tutto quanto con i sample però a
parte il cambiamento dei sound se c'è
una cosa che ma sempre veramente tanto
tanto tanto affascinato
il modo in cui cambia la scrittura in
cui cambia la scrittura le melodie la
parte più autoriale
poi io sono
per non solo se la persona molto fissata
faccio molta ricerca
facciamo finta tornare indietro nel
tempo
72 esce un disco postumo di luigi tenco
che si chiama tenco canta tenco de andrè
jannacci e bob dylan e quel disco è
presente
un brano che si chiama la ballata della
moda che racconta in modo ironico in un
modo molto romanzato
come le masse diventino vittima del
consumismo e della moda
lo racconta tramite questo cameriera
antonio che serve un tavolo dei grandi
industriali
lui all'inizio
e deride il prodotto dei grandi
industriali
fino a poi diventarne così tanta
assuefatto è dipendente da finire
all'ospedale
chiamava acqua blu non penso sia mai
esistita quindi lo posso dire
la scrittura non era soltanto politica
ma anche politica c'era anche una corale
ma se andiamo poco poco più avanti nel
73 esce un brano molto particolare un
non so che di molto attuale
si chiama alice di francesco de gregori
alice scatta delle foto cioè l'autore
scatta delle foto a delle situazioni
quindi il mendicante arabo che ha un
cancro nel cappello ma è convinto che se
è un portafortuna
alice guarda i gatti i capi muoiono nel
sole mentre il sole cose a poco si
avvicina
o lo sposo che durante il matrimonio pur
sapendo che la moglie è incinta si alza
per dire di no
pur sapendo quale sarà il suo destino il
bravo ruota tutto intorno a questa
grande in innocenza di alice alice non
lo sa ma tutto questo alice non lo sa
la qualità di questo modo di scrivere
sta proprio nel fatto che nel 2017 è
sembra è un disco in italia che siano
con la ride che non fa altro che
scattare delle foto la mondanità romana
alla gioventù in un certo senso
è questo
questo disco di franco 127 braves
riesce appieno a rappresentare tutta la
giovinezza romana tutta l'emotività dei
ragazzi e qui ritorniamo all'inizio i
ragazzi sentono quelle parole sentono
noi deridiamo anche se stiamo messi male
il mio amico stacca 8 immediatezza costo
oppure la componente emotiva ci avrei
scommesso sulle due una vita intera
sempre in due e invece almeno delle sue
i ragazzi ascoltano rielaborano e
pensano quasi che queste canzoni sono
state scritte per loro che raccontano la
loro vita e questa è la potenza vera
della musica
ora io mi sono chiesto come sarà la
musica nel 2050 ma quando poi sono
andate effettivamente da un'amica mia
degli esami sto parlando un po
come sarà la musica nel 2050 le ma
guardando mi ha detto che me ne frega di
come sarà la musica al 2050
e secondo me ha ragione lei e cioè
il mio discorso infatti non vuole
perdere su questo ma sul essere pronti
tra 30 anni
a non aver perso quella voglia di
ascoltare e di immedesimarsi nelle
necessità e dei bisogni degli altri
perché spesso ce lo scordiamo ce lo
ricordiamo tanto quando siamo giovani
quando siamo ragazzi va un certo punto
rimpiangiamo sempre un'epoca d'oro siamo
sempre alla ricerca di quello che era il
passato di quello che ci ricorda
ciò che siamo stati a giovani
però tutto questo porta vasco rossi ad
arrivare
ultimo al festival della canzone
italiana
e
porta tutta quanta un'altra serie di
cose e quindi io spero in questi
trent'anni no di
se ascoltate questo discorso
di ricordarvi che i bisogni cambiano ma
non è che non esiste un adesso non meno
importanti perché i ragazzi di oggi
ragazzi e ciano 15 anni 16 anni cantano
che si sentono teorica parlano della
dell'anziano che si diceva di moda
quest'ansia non patti come se i ragazzi
29 sono dei problemi c'era allo stesso
modo c'è tanta rivalsa sociale economica
ragazzi che vengono da lì niente
riescono a costruirsi un futuro
tramite la musica
e quindi gli altri ragazzi la musica
cambia il mondo nel mondo cambia la
musica
non abbiate paura di precursori e non
facciamo gli stessi errori di fatto
arriva vasco rossi ultimo al festival
della canzone italiana
grazie
[Applauso]